I've always wanted to direct and I never
felt ready I never felt like I had
enough experience enough time being on
set and around directors and then I
thought it's time to jump kid you gotta
you gotta do it even though it's scary
you have to give yourself the chance I
think it was just I had the bravado that
I could make this movie anyway I had
bravado when I walked into people's
office when they look at the script well
you know we don't like this and can you
change the third act all that stuff I
was like well you know I can't you know
this is the movie I want to make and I
can make it over here this way so thank
you very much but no thank you when you
stop asking permission and start just
taking Destiny in your own hands things
kind of fall into place like that and
yeah and I saw that my dad never gave up
he was always really persevered and I
don't know lately I've been trying to
start a film project and I'm waiting for
the company to give me the go ahead and
he's like just start it so the idea you
don't wait for permission you just do
you just do things and hopefully people
will follow them